if someone speaks a little bit of German
and gets complimented or Japanese
they're very proud of themselves that
they were able to say anything at all in
those languages that they've learned
whereas with English that's not good
enough with English there's a feeling
that I have to be almost like a native
speaker hi Jennifer hi Steve thanks so
much for having me thank you no I'm
looking forward to talking to you you do
very important work you teach English
and in particular with English you often
hear about people who are afraid to
speak or think they don't speak very
well and yet these are people who have
spent years and years with English and
so I ask myself there's more resources
available for learning English than any
other language so why is it that these
people still feel not satisfied with
their level in English in your opinion
that's a great question and a lot of it
I think comes down to their
expectation they have this expectation
that they're going to be able to
communicate the same way as a native
speaker my students always compare the
way they speak in English to the way I
speak in English they are upset because
are their accent isn't the exact same as
mine or their vocabulary isn't Advanced
as mine and obviously is just not a fair
comparison and also I find that the
students learning English a lot of them
that I have they've been learning
English their entire lives but
throughout their lives learning English
they've been in these environments where
they're constantly assessed they're
constantly assessed with language exams
they're constantly told they're making
mistakes and they've developed this this
fear of using their English or they
expect Perfection because of how often
they're assessed and then they don't
realize when they get into the
professional World The Working World or
even social environment that the
language is not so rigid and there's a
lot more flexibility with the language
in the real world I think you raised a
few very good points there first of all
it seems that people have higher
expectations of themselves when it comes
to English than they do for other
languages so if someone speaks a little
bit of German and gets complimented or
Japanese they're very proud of
themselves that they were able to say
anything at all in those languages that
they've learned whereas with English
that's not good enough with English
there's a feeling that I have to be
almost like a native speaker and of
course that's simply not possible that's
so true and also I find that my students
they also compare how they speak in
English to how they speak in their own
native language which also is not a fair
comparison obviously and this creates a
lot of anxiety in them because they
think about how they would answer a
question in their native language and
then when they go to answer that
question in English they struggle a
little bit more the words don't flow as
easily and they see this as a huge
problem and they see this as well I'm
not fluent I'll never progress my
English is terrible but of course they
can't compare it to a native speaker and
they can't compare it to how they speak
in their own language oh absolutely I
mean when you consider how much we have
read and how much we have listened to
our native language so the brain has so
much experience with the language so
that's again why I emphasize input you
can't get to that level of input
experience with the language but the
more you invest in getting exposure to
the language the the more weapons you
will have when you go to speak have you
had success stories where people have
come to you and and obviously we
struggling and were you able to find
ways to help them improve yes thankfully
I have had Success With Many students so
first I had to think about all the
mistakes that students were making and
what was really preventing them from
reaching their goal again their goal is
just communicating in English I realized
that there were really two things we
needed to do we had to fix their mindset
because they had to get over that fear
of making mistakes that fear of being
judged how critical they are of
themselves when they're speaking so
addressing those and just helping them
relax and have fun speaking and just see
it in a different way really help them
to progress with their speaking skills
and for the more technical language
skills vocabulary grammar Expressions it
was by helping them get content get
input that they really enjoyed so for my
students I helped them learn with TV
shows YouTube videos movies newspaper
articles short stories and they enjoy
learning with this content and it's
natural content it teaches you how to
use the language in the real world there
again I think two important points that
you made the greater the variety of
input the more comfortable you're going
to be in the language but you know more
than anything else relax and enjoy the
process so I will leave a link to your
YouTube channel in the description box
tell us again where people can find you
well if you're learning English as a
second language then you can find me on
YouTube at J Forest English well I
encourage people to go look for you and
to enjoyed the process thank you very
much Jennifer I enjoyed this discussion
very much thank you so much Steve it's
been a pleasure